my name is rabbi avraham Berkowitz with
chabad lubavitch the global Jewish
organization bringing Jewish life and
spiritual and cultural support
throughout the world but so special
about the World Economic Forum is really
in its slogan improving the state of the
world there is nothing more important in
a multi-stakeholder conversation it's
not just about business the business
government and business you have to
really bring the various powers and
influencers within a society together
both from the labor unions to the NGOs
to the faith communities and it's really
an honor that the World Economic Forum
sees their role with great power and
influence from the world of business and
government to work together with all
those that are trying to improve the
state of the world and there's nowhere
that you see this more than in a country
like India where the inequality is so
vast or 17 hundred million people in
India live in villages on less than a
dollar a day and if we believe in the
Bible chapter 1 verse 26 that we're all
created equally in the image of God and
we have to find ways to leverage the
food supply and clean water and
conflicts for the masses that don't have
the privilege and opportunity that those
in the highest percentile have we should
only be blessed with reaching the true
goals of improving the state of the
world for all of humanity